[موسيقى]
يضم البحر الأحمر بعضًا من أفضل
الشعاب المرجانية في العالم وموطنًا لمجموعة متنوعة غير عادية
من الحياة البحرية مع إطار أنيق
من اللون الأزرق اللامع والرمادي يمكن التعرف على
دلفين المحيط الهادئ قاروري الأنف
على الفور وستجدهم بالقرب
من الجونة
عالمة الأحياء البحرية بوفرة أنجيلا الطمي نور
هي تهمس دولفين في الحياة الواقعية لقد
اتبعت كل تحركاتها على مدار عقد من الزمان
ولدينا حوالي 300 دلافين على حدة في هذه المنطقة ،
أدركت مدى أهمية معرفة
المزيد الذي يمكنك أيضًا حمايته  يركز
جزء كبير من أبحاث أنجيلا على الحيوانات التي
تركز على
أنماط نوم الدلافين التي اكتشفت أنها
تصطاد في المحيط ليلًا وتعود
إلى الشعاب المرجانية أثناء النهار
للنوم ، ومن المثير للاهتمام حقًا كيف
تنام الدلافين فهي تنام فقط
بدماغ واحد  الجانب الأول مستيقظ
والآخر نائم ولكن عمل أنجيلا
ليس فقط للأغراض العلمية ، فقواعد
السلوك مهمة جدًا
للقباطنة في جو  بالإضافة إلى تعليم
الضيوف السياح أنهم يعرفون
أنه لا يمكننا السباحة الآن لأن
الدلافين تنام لأن المزيد والمزيد من الزوار
يتدفقون على الشعاب المرجانية ، فإن بحثها
يوجه تجربتهم غالبًا ما
تأخذ أنجيلا الزوار في رحلات يومية إلى
الشعاب المرجانية المحمية التي تسمى شرم.  إلغ عندما
تأتي الكائنات البحرية إليك
مثل أننا لسنا نشيطين في ملاحقتها ،
فالجميع يحب أن يرى
الدلافين وحتى الغوص معهم ولكن
لهذا عليك أن تعرف كيف تتفاعل
معهم بطريقة مستدامة كما
هم  لا تغادر المناطق
التي رأيناها للتو ،
اسمها لورا ، إنها غالبًا ما
تجمع العلم ومشاهدة المعالم السياحية
معًا ، يستفيد السائحون من
خبرة أنجيلا فهم على دراية بك ،
وإذا أرادوا التفاعل ، فهم قادمون
دعهم يقررون ما إذا كانوا يريدون
لمقابلته إذا لم يرغبوا في تركهم
هذا اختيارهم ويجب علينا احترامه
[موسيقى]